Tonight, our family is hunkering down
to spend some cozy time together at home,
and I am partnering with Albertsons to make something
really yummy for dinner.
Come with me to Albertsons to pick up everything I need.
Albertsons drive up and go
makes it so quick for me to get everything I need
without having to get myself or my kiddos
out of the car.
I am home, I have all my ingredients,
and I'm ready to make some yummy dip.
My husband is a huge sports fan,
so that's what's on the docket tonight,
but he's also a huge food fan,
and I love how this recipe tastes so fresh and homemade.
When I use good ingredients,
the fresh corn makes a huge difference,
and Albertson says
all of my go to fresh and pantry staples.
Now everything is ready to go
for our closing night at home together.